- So I heard you met Prince
and we have this thing on this show.
Everybody has a Prince story.
I don't, but everybody else does.
And, I wanna know, what
was your experience?
- My Prince story is that I got a meeting
like a general meeting that
goes meet with this director
and they said, "And Prince."
And I thought like Prince Johnson
from Santa Monica or something.
(audience laughing)
- oh, you didn't know
it was actually prince
that you were seeing?
- I had no idea.
- Oh, that makes me sweat.
- Me too.
- Yeah.
- Even now.
And so I rescheduled the meeting twice,
'cause I had a bunch of stuff going on.
They were like are you gonna-
- You reschedule on Prince.
- You schedule on Prince?
- I know.
(audience laugh)
So the last time they were like,
"You're either coming or you're not."
And I was like, "Okay, I'm coming."
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
So then I come
to this meeting at this house
and as soon as I get on the
elevator, that's in the house.
I'm like, "What is an
elevator in a house?"
The doors open and it's
crush purple velvet.
And I'm like, "Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait."
And so I look back at the director,
I'm like, "I'm fine."
- I'm fine. (laughs)
- And then the door closes
and the emblem's right there.
And I was like, I'm flipping out.
Like I'm such a hip Prince fan.
- Everyone is, I would
be sweating so much.
- When I tell you,
- You just figured that out
right before you met him.
- I did not know what to do with myself.
- Oh no.
- So then he comes out of the hallway
and she's like, "Prince Megan's here."
And I'm like, "What?"
So he comes around the hallway,
He has these little Chinese pajamas
and he has on like these three chills
and his hair is tied up.
He's got his powder and his eyeliner.
And he was like, "Would
you like something to eat?"
And I was like, "Yes, yes."
Mind you I had just eaten.
And so we go, we sit down,
and we're sitting at the table
and he's like, "Do you want salad?"
And I was like, "I would love salad."
I hate salad, now I'm better.
- I love salad though.
- Now I do.
But back then I was like, "Yes."
And then he was like, "Okay."
And then the person was like,
"Well do you want salad Prince?"
And he was like, "No."
I was like, "I don't want it either."
And then it just sounded
like I was like copying him.
I was like, "No, but I really don't.
I don't really eat salad that much.
It's okay."
(Kelly laughing)
And then if they brought out wine
and literally as the woman's
walking back in the kitchen
Prince is like, (clears throat)
and she's like, "Oh, I'm sorry. I forgot."
She comes back out with
a bright green straw
like a child's straw and
folds it over for him
and puts it in his red wine.
And I was just like, okay.
And I'm just watching like everything
and like the table's long
and he's at the head of it
and me and the director at the other side.
And I looked down and I can see his feet
are about this far from the ground.
And I can see him kind of going like that.
And then like, he was
like making little shapes
on the table was the awkwardest dinner.
And I had no idea why I was
there and what was going on.
And then by the end of it, he was like,
"I wanna make this documentary
about a young Malcolm X,
and I want you to play the character
and I wanna show it to you."
And I was like, "Oh, okay."
So then we watched a little
bit of documentary then I left
and then I pulled down the
street and I called my mom.
I was like, "Mommy!"
And like screaming.
And then I like, literally, I
was like, "Can you hear me?"
And she's like, "What happened?
Did you get in a car accident?
I can't understand you."
- Oh no.
(audience laughing)
- And I was like, "No,
I'm trying to say that.
I just met Prince."
And so yeah, best, best day ever.
- Can I-
(audience clapping)
- Can I tell you that
I'm actually still back
where he asked for bright green straw?
It's wine.
- Yeah, I was like,
maybe he's a germophobe.
I don't know, I was
trying to put it together.
- Oh gosh, that's amazing.
I'm like so weird, I wouldn't
have been able to let that go.
The whole dinner I'd have been like,
"Why?"
- Not really?
- I probably would've
had to have asked him.
That's why I've never met Prince.
He knew, he knew, don't invite
that weirdo to my house.
Have you ever met Prince?
Did you ever meet him?
- No.
- Okay.
Yeah, we don't have cool stories.
Yeah. I'm not cool either.
It's like, everyone has one, it's crazy.
- Oh, I have a Prince story,
but it doesn't involve meeting him.
- Oh wait, I wanna know the Prince story.
- You remember those little records,
they were like 33 and a
thirds back in the day.
So they used to give those
out at bar mitzvah parties,
like if you won the limbo contest.
I was 10 years old.
It was my older brother's
friend's bar mitzvah.
And that was the prize
was "Erotic City" on 33.
Now, if you listen to "Erotic",
- [Kelly] What?
- not appropriate for a 10-year-old.
(audience laugh)
It's my Prince story.
- I love that they gave that out.
- That is really wild.
(audience clapping)
- Y'all know how to party, insane.
- I wasn't really the limbo person.
(all laughing)
- Limbo and some Prince, I love it.